What
it is,
well,
let's step back,
what is it?
Bio dynamic wine.
There is a guy named Rudolf Steiner who,
a founder,
the founder,
the bite,
oh,
dynamic one movement and he had very
quirky ideas about making one,
but um,
many of these practices have proved to
um,
improve the sort of the vineyards,
the health of the vineyards and that's
what really we're talking about having
healthy vines and healthy healthy
grapes.
He was interested in harvesting in the
moonlight.
He was interested in um,
cow horns filled with dung,
planted in the vineyard.
So there's some quirky things that go
along with biodynamic wine.
Um,
but,
but basically we're talking about the
health of the vineyard and if you have a
healthy vineyard,
you should have a really great one with
organic.
It's actually a tricky proposition
because in terms of winemaking,
you,
what you're looking at usually is
organic grapes,
but there's an entire organic wine
making process that sometimes wine
makers will not carry through.
So is it.
The labeling is a little dicey.
So I think what we'll see is wines made
from organic grips,
probably not the entire process.
The ones that are,
um,
that are green and that,
are not always reliable are the ones
that are made without sulfites.
And so I'm in France,
there's an enormous movement and there's
wine bars that just have these,
you know,
great ones,
green ones.
I mean,
without sulphites,
those ones aren't very stable.
Um,
because the sulfites helped to stabilize
the wine.
So,
um,
that I think is where you can get an
amazing,
amazing wine
without sulfites.
But boy,
you have to be complete.